afternoon everybody thank you for coming
here this afternoon to this press
conference my name is superintendent
Richard Harris I'm going to read to you
a short statement
and I'll hand you over to my colleague
from the fire service
it will also really short statements and
then we will take some questions from
yourselves so first and foremost on
behalf of everybody in the community and
on behalf of Westminster please I'd like
to pass on our deepest sympathies at
this time
the tragic circumstances yesterday
afternoon
so close to Christmas time and our
sympathies with the families who have
lost loved ones in this incident I'd
also like to say that we are supporting
the families we have specialist trained
officers who are linking in with the
families at this time to offer them as
much support as we possibly can
we've also linked in with the local
schools which the children attended
within this area and the schools are
also offering support to many pupils who
may wish to receive support at this
awful time
our officers were quick to respond at
the scene yesterday afternoon and having
worked very closely with our colleagues
from other Emergency Services went into
the lake itself to help rescue the
children and to try and assist them as
quickly as we possibly could
we've worked very closely with our
colleagues in westman's fire service and
also in westman's Ambulance Service and
this has been a real joint effort
it is incredibly sad that we do not have
any better news for you today
regarding yesterday afternoon's incident
that's all I have to say at this moment
in time we're going to pass over to to
my colleague now from the fire service
and then we'll we'll be open to take any
questions thank you Richard
we are deeply saddened by the death of
three boys who were rescued by our
firefighters yesterday here at the lake
in solihull
the boy's deaths are a tragedy beyond
words
and the thoughts and heartfelt
sympathies of everyone here at
westminants fire services with their
families friends and The Wider
communities at this distressing time
yesterday's incident is a start reminder
to us all of the dangers of Open Water
especially during the winter months
frozen lakes ponds canals and reservoirs
can look picturesque but they can be
lethal and there are no greater warnings
of this than yesterday's tragic events
we would ask parents and carers to
remind their children of the dangers of
ice and why they must keep off it please
help us to avoid this from happening
again
we will continue to work closely with
our emergency service colleagues and
provide any support that we can at the
scene
again we extend our heartfelt sympathies
to everyone who has been affected by the
police deaths
dependence on parliamentary from Sky
News can you just
give us some information regarding the
ongoing work here at the lake and
whether or not there are further people
unaccounted for so yes yes to the
evening we had a number of different
reports suggesting numbers of young
people that may have been on the lake
those reports don't match the children
that were rescued from the lake
yesterday however we have to be 100
certain that there is no one else and
possibly in the war at this time
we it's important to stress though that
we've had no contact from anybody
suggesting that there's anybody else
missing but until we're 100 certain we
will be carrying on searches throughout
the course of today
news and how long do you expect to be
here
as long as it takes we've got specialist
Crews and we've got specialist equipment
that's in the water that allows us to
see what's in the water so we'll be here
for as long as it takes us so we're
absolutely certain there is no one left
three
at this moment in time that the family's
request we're not going to go into those
details we're working very closely with
the family and supporting them as you
can imagine that we are when the family
are ready to release those details then
we will let you know
the the other boy at the moment he's
still very poorly and will keep you
advised on on his condition as uh as if
you come to clinics ourselves yes
we have been in touch with with the
local schools and again at the family's
request we're not going to go into too
much detail around uh names or the
actual schools that the children
I'm not going to make a comment on that
one at this time I'm sure you'll
understand the family's wishes there are
reports that one of the children went to
rescue one who whose leg had gone
through the eyes are you able to confirm
that
again at this moment in time the
families of us just not to release any
further details than what I'm able to
provide you this morning I'm afraid as
soon as the families are are happy we
will be able to release you some more
information on that
family as you can imagine uh absolutely
devastated
um
also at this time of year it's it's on
the run-up to Christmas
um so close to the to the event itself
um also adds to that tragedy but as you
can imagine the families are absolutely
devastated which is why we're we're
doing our very best to support the
families and obviously we're we're
abiding by their requests at the moment
as to how much information that the
families want us to to make available to
to the media so we're doing everything
we possibly can to to support them and
I'm sure you'll understand that we are
led by the family's wishes as to how
much information that we can say at the
moment we've seen footage that police
officers initially went into the water
to help pull the children out with their
members of the public as well and just
How brave were those people who did that
so
um from my understanding is yes police
officers did go into into the water they
were joined by other members of the
other Emergency Services some of the
officers went in Waist Deep
one of my offices
trying to punch through the ice to to
actually rescue the children themselves
that officer
as a result of that had some mild
hypothermia yesterday I'm pleased to say
that he's now being released from
hospital and he's absolutely fine in
relation to and I'm sure again you'll
understand we're still trying to work
through all the details that that came
into us last night we've got quite a few
witnesses that we need to we need to
speak to and we're currently still
working through that at the moment I'd
just like to take this opportunity just
ready to make an appeal that if anybody
has any information
or saw any events that took place
yesterday afternoon leading up to this
tragic incident if they could go on to
our West Midlands police website there
are contact details on there on how to
get in touch with us and then officers
will be in touch in due course but we're
still trying to piece together exactly
what happened leading up to uh to
yesterday afternoon events
services
to go in how they can use
so as I say yesterday's incident is
tragic and everybody within the fire
service Community will feel that
they did everything they could under the
circumstances to get into the water to
rescue the four boys and to bring them
out to the ambulance Series so that they
could receive treatment but you will
appreciate they are you know deeply
disappointed by the news that we've been
told today
it sounds like the response was quick
but inevitably it takes a month's time
for emergency services to get here can
you give us an indication of how long
the children were in the water
at this moment of time I don't have the
answer to that question the officers and
other services arrived as as quickly as
we were in forms
um at that time the the call which came
into US was a 234 PM so it was in
minutes with the report coming in that
we arrived at the seat but the exact
time of the children exposing the water
I don't have that information at this
time
foreign
so for the fire service we arrived on
the scene quickly alongside our
colleagues in the police and ambulance
service it is quite a large lake and it
did take some time in order to identify
exactly where their point of entry was
but as soon as that was established
firefighters entered the water alongside
colleagues and members of the public in
order to try and rescue them as quickly
as possible
officers went straight in yes we were
without regard to their own safety they
enter the order in just their normal
trousers and shoots which is more like
wearing today so they went in just the
time
I had a very similar picture for the
fire service our initial Crews that
arrived on scene made their way straight
into the water in their normal
firefighting kit and then when the
specialist water rescue teams came along
they entered the water with with
different levels of PPE
there are no injuries to Firefighters
that Apple made aware of
if you have any more information on the
members of the public who apparently
rushed him to help
I don't at this time will as those
details come through we'll we'll let you
know but at tonight in time sorry I
don't have her
first one
um not again at the families request I'm
not going to go into actual details
around the children themselves and the
condition but as soon as the family are
happy for us to release that well
the port side has he been treated at
Birmingham Children's Hospital
I'm not going to get as the families
request we're not going to diverge which
hospitals the children went to
few of the children were accompanied by
an adult
there again at the at the family's
request I'm not going to release any
further information around that until
they're happy for us to to release any
further details
there's no suggestion of any criminal
investigation
at the moment we from a policing
perspective we our main concern is to
support the families at this tragic time
we're not currently looking at any any
criminal investigation
thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you